il s'agit quand même de décaler le
versement des allocations familiales
c'està dire les allocations qui sont
versées pour les enfants c'est
celle-là non al les allocations
familiales je sais pas ce que là ce qui
est écrit c'est les allocations familial
donc je je ressors le
codeocation familiales basique c'est ça
que vous voulez dire monsieur le
rapporteur les allocations familiales
celles qui sont versées à l'arrivée du
premier enfant voilà le deuxè enfant
c'est celle c'est bien celle-là dont on
parle
les premier enfant dans un certain
nombre de lesucations sont versé dans un
nbre de cas sous condition de ressources
je pense à la prime de naissance par
exemple pour le premier enfant dès le
premier enfant puis ensuite des
allocations familiales bref je être sûr
qu'on parle bien de la même chose donc
on parle vous parlez de prestation non
contributive je crois savoir que les une
personne peut être en France on parle de
de travailleurs en situation régulière
hein ça touche pas les en situation
irrégulière en situation régulière
travailler cotiser à la à l'URSAF payer
des cotisations à la branche famille et
on le et vous proposez de le priver de
priver ses enfants des allocations
familiales c'està dire que vous
organiser la pauvreté des enfants dans
des familles régulièrement installées en
France et travaillant en France je crois
que là soit vous n'êtes pas sérieux soit
on touche le fond merci chers collègues
monsieur le
[Musique]
ministre